même selon en bas on va revenir un
artiste on va revenir on va revenir à
l'artiste on va revenir aux poètes avec
une interview en un mot quel est le mot
qui sonne le mieux dans la langue
française pour toi pontault combault
quel est le mot que tu préfères entendre
en anglais fuck you
quel est le mot qui n'a jamais dit à une
femme fuck you
quels mots que tu n'as jamais dit un
homme fait nuit
quel est le bon ceci je voudrais pas
entendre dans la bouche d'un enfant
sécurité de l'emploi quel est le mot qui
pourrait te faire tout quitter pareil
quel est le mot qui revient le plus
souvent dans tes chansons
la vie quel est le mot qui revient le
plus souvent dans ta tête des sentiments
quel est le nom qui revient le plus
souvent quand on parle de toi quel est
le mot qui te rappelle ton meilleur
souvenir premiers rôles en cas ça c'est
à dire quel est le mot qui résume ses
faiblesses dans la vie les chiites
quels mots qui donnent envie de gagner
tu as tout perdu quels mots qui donnent
envie de pleurer
ludovic faire un
ces fichiers pour lui quel est le mot
que tu voudrais qu'on graves sur la
pierre tombale ni la révolution
l'album s'appelle les anime
là